How you doing, good?
Please, touch my leg any time you like.
Hello!
I heard in the back that you
have a problem, mentally,
about the shape of your butt.
First of all--
Really, though--
To be honest,
it's really more of the lack
of the shape of the butt.
But I--
why are people talking
about my butt backstage?
No.
Those are people
that work for me.
It's not that, they asked me questions,
and they said--
Okay.
Can you train?
He doesn't need to be trained.
Conan has a nice butt.
I Shouldn't even
be here tonight.
He believe his butt is concave.
I don't have Jean-Claude.
Jean-Claude Van Damme
thinks you have a nice butt.
Yes, so sorry.
Thanks for giving me a chance here guys.
I don't have much of a butt,
I've never had much of a
butt and I don't know--
You have a good butt.
What's that, I have a good butt?
Yeah, let me feel it.
Is it good?
It's really strong, yeah.
It's like.
yeah, yeah, yeah.
You turn your butt on my face.
Yes, in my country that is
a sign of great respect.
Yeah.
I don't know how they do
things in Brussels but--
Thank God.
You did ask to touch it.
So you think there's hope for me.
You think there's some butt there
that I could work with that.
Yes, by laying on the floor.
You lay on the floor and
you contract your buttocks
for three seconds.
One, two, three.
On your back or on your stomach?
You stay on your back, right?
Men and women, men and
women you stay on your back.
Lay on your back, lay on your back.
All you have to do is to
contract your buttocks.
Go!
I've been doing that since I was like, 11.
One, two, three, relax.
Okay, then relax.
And then you wait two
seconds and again, go.
One, two, not too strong for the back.
Not too strong?
For the back, no go and relax.
Okay.
And again.
This is such a (beep) weird thing for me.
You do this three times 30 a day
next day you cannot walk.
That contraction is very good.
Well great, no.
What do you mean I can't walk?
You remember, one, two, three relax.
One, two, three relax.
Three times--
Like butt kegels.
Yes it's just by contracting
it gets so strong.
You know I gotta ask you about this
'cause it's something
that's fascinated me--
Inexpensive, huh?
What's that?
I mean it's inexpensive.
Inexpensive yes, it's an inexpensive--
And you can do it anywhere,
Starbucks wherever.
Lay on the floor, go right ahead.